Regarde ça, regarde ça.
Ils nous prennent en sandwich.
Hallucinant !
Bonjour à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo.
Aujourd’hui, je suis à bord du Sam Simon,
l’un des bateaux de l’ONG Sea Shepherd,
qui sont en train de mener des opérations
au large des côtes françaises
pour alerter du sort des dauphins
qui sont en train de se faire massacrer.
C'est ce qu’on va vous expliquer
dans cette vidéo.
C’est fou, là, il y a le radar
et on voit tous les bateaux de la zone.
Enfin c’est basique mais tu repères
tous les bateaux des alentours.
On va aller se renseigner
auprès du capitaine
pour savoir où on va exactement
parce que pour l’instant,
je ne sais pas quel est
le mode opératoire, en fait.
- Comment vous commencez
l’opération ?
Vous prenez un cap ?
- Alors là en fait,
on observe sur l’AIS
qui est un système électronique
d’identification des navires.
Donc, les navires de pêche
doivent avoir cet AIS en route,
donc nous, ça nous permet de savoir
à quel endroit ils sont.
Après maintenant, on connaît les zones
où ils pêchent d’habitude
donc on va aller sur la même zone qu’eux
pour pouvoir contrôler
la remontée des filets durant la nuit.
- Comment ça se passe
avec les chalutiers ?
- Alors ce qu’on fait avec les chalutiers,
c’est qu’on reste un petit peu à l’écart
et après on envoie nos bateaux rapides,
nos deux Zodiacs,
pour aller observer de près,
en même temps
sans les déranger dans leur pêche.
- Pourquoi vous ne voulez pas
les déranger ?
- Parce que c’est légal,
leur activité de pêche est légale,
donc nous, on est là vraiment
pour observer, pour voir ce qu’ils font
et pour alerter les gens
et l’opinion publique sur ce qu’il se passe.
On est la seule présence, en fait,
sur la côte ouest et dans le golfe de Gascogne
pour monitorer ce qu’il se passe,
donc c’est une campagne importante
parce que personne d’autre n’est là.
Ça y’est, on a levé l’ancre
et là, on part en mer
et le but, c’est d’aller approcher les chalutiers qui sont en train de pêcher.
Et généralement, c’est plutôt de nuit
que les opérations se déroulent,
que l’action commence.
Il est une heure du matin,
on s’est levés il y a à peine 10 minutes
et on attaque maintenant,
l’opération commence.
Go ! Go ! Go ! Go !
Ça, c’est la manœuvre classique
pour mettre les bateaux à l’eau
et après nous, passagers,
on va passer par une petite échelle
pour rejoindre le bateau par le côté.
Faut pas se rater.
Il y a beaucoup de houle.
Ça bouge pas mal,
on est à fond, dans la nuit totale !
C'est énorme.
Je ne vois même pas le bateau,
je ne vois même pas
une lumière de bateau.
Ils se servent simplement
du radar pour se diriger.
Wouaaaaah !
On s'approche gentiment
des chalutiers,
on commence à voir les lumières.
On vient d'arriver juste à côté.
Ok, ça y est, les bateaux
sont à côté de nous.
Pour bien vous expliquer,
les deux bateaux-là, ils sont côte à côte,
c'est ce qu'on appelle
dans le langage maritime "en bœuf"
et ensemble, ils tirent
un énorme filet qu'on appelle pélagique,
parce qu'il évolue tout seul dans l'eau,
sans toucher le fond,
en forme d'entonnoir,
pour attraper les poissons.
Le problème, c'est que le dauphin
va s'approcher des filets,
il va être curieux
et c'est là qu'il se prend dans les filets
parce qu'il veut chasser,
et il ne va pas faire la différence
ou il va complètement être attiré
par les poissons.
- Alors, qu’est-ce qu’il se passe
maintenant ?
- Ils sont en train de chaluter,
donc on va attendre
que les deux bateaux se rapprochent.
Ils pêchent ensemble pour pouvoir
couvrir un plus grand espace avec le filet.
- Donc on reste en stationnaire ici
pendant deux, trois heures
et on observe ce qu’il se passe ?
- On est déjà restés 8 heures.
- Ok !
- Parce qu'ils ne remontent pas
tout le temps en fait.
- Là, ils sont en train de nous observer,
ils nous regardent un petit peu,
ils savent qu’on est là,
en plus avec la lumière de la caméra...
- Ouais, ils savent qu’on est là.
Ceux-là, ils nous ont déjà
insulté dans le passé
et ils vont sûrement le faire ce soir
mais quand ils vont donner le filet,
ils vont essayer de nous chasser aussi
pour essayer de pousser,
comme ça,
s'il y a quelque chose dans le filet,
ils espèrent qu’on ne le verra pas.
En général, ça ne marche pas
parce qu’on est plus rapides qu’eux
et beaucoup plus maniables.
Maintenant, c’est la phase d’observation,
la phase d’attente
et on va attendre
à peu près deux heures,
mais ça, c’est le minimum,
ça peut être encore plus.
Le temps qu’ils remontent les filets.
Ça fait à peu près
deux heures qu’on attend.
Deux heures,
deux heures et demie
et le filet n’est toujours pas remonté.
Il commence à faire un peu froid
et on attend.
Qu'est-ce qu'il fait là ?
Il fait une manœuvre bizarre
le deuxième ?
Ils sont en train de relever...
- Regarde, filme, il y va !
- Regarde !
Ok, il est en train de chasser
le deuxième Zodiac de Sea Shepherd,
il fonce dessus !
C'est hyper dangereux
comme manœuvre ça !
Là, en dix minutes,
toute la situation se retourne
avec les chalutiers qui commencent
à chasser les bateaux de Sea Shepherd
et vraiment en mode "rien à foutre" tu vois,
ils nous foncent dessus.
C’est assez impressionnant,
il y a une sorte de tension.
Putain !
C’est ouf !
Ils replient le filet avec une énorme poulie sur le bateau,
rattachée à plein de câbles dégueulasses.
Putain, c’est vraiment une...
une chimère !
Regarde ça !
- Eh vous, bande de gros pédés !
C’est vraiment plein de câbles, plein de merdiers,
je ne pensais pas que c’était aussi gros
et là, ils n’ont pas encore fini de le ramener.
Ça tire sur des...
des centaines de mètres facile, facile !
Putain !
Oh la taille du filet quoi !
Rolala, c’est infini !
- Oh la belle brochette d'abrutis !
- Hein, vous venez nous casser
les couilles là, hein !
- Faire chier le monde qui travaille,
ça vous savez faire hein !
Non bah écoute, pas de dauphins,
pas de requins.
Fais gaffe, l'autre, je pense
qu'il va nous venir dessus,
au dernier moment.
- Allez, viens-là !
Regarde ça, regarde ça.
Ils nous prennent en sandwich.
Hallucinant !
Ils essaient de faire peur.
Tu as bien vu comme
ils se sont resserrés sur nous
pour faire de l'intimidation.
C’était assez tendu
parce que nous on est tendus,
on ne veut pas voir les animaux
dans les filets.
On est là pour regarder.
Les pêcheurs, ils nous insultent
mais voilà, ce n’est pas incroyable.
Ils sont en train de travailler,
il ne faut pas non plus blâmer les gens,
ce n’est pas aussi simple que ça.
Bon, il n’y avait pas de dauphins
mais surtout, ce qui m’a choqué,
c’est qu’il n’y avait aucun poisson.
T’imagines que ces filets-là,
qui font des centaines de mètres,
ils sont laissés
cinq à six heures dans l’eau
et il n’y a rien comme poissons quoi !
On rentre à la maison.
Je pense que les actions de Sea Shepherd
sont super importantes
parce qu’il faut des gens
qui créent des pétitions,
des gens qui sont plus calmes,
qui vont plus faire des choses politiques.
Mais il faut aussi des gens
qui sont sur le terrain
et qui fracassent quoi,
qui font des choses comme ils font.
Aujourd’hui, ils sont très calmes ici,
sur cette mission,
mais c’est important
parce que ça fait parler, ça fait bouger.
C’est ultra épuisant comme taf,
ils sont tous bénévoles,
les mecs sont sur-déter…
Vraiment, il y a une espèce
de fraternité entre eux,
c’est incroyable, une famille...
Et ils font ça tous les jours, tu vois,
depuis un mois pour certains,
donc c’est assez violent.
J’avais beaucoup entendu parler
de la pêche intensive
mais je ne me rendais pas compte.
C’est toujours la même chose,
c’est quand tu vois devant toi
que tu as une prise de conscience.
Je pense que le problème,
ce n’est pas forcément les pêcheurs.
Eux, ils effectuent juste
les besoins d’une demande,
c’est-à-dire de nous, citoyens,
qui consommons de plus en plus du poisson
C’est peut-être nous
qui devons évoluer
et adapter nos méthodes
de consommation
et après en découle évidemment...
Tout ce qui est industriel va,
peut-être, se modifier et arrêter d’exister.
Pour nous,
il faudrait interdire certaines pratiques,
certaines techniques de pêche
parce qu’on sait qu’elles ne sont pas sélectives.
Je pense qu’on est à une époque
où les gens ont envie de savoir
d'où viennent les produits
qu'ils consomment.
Les gens demandent de plus en plus
de traçabilité.
Si on leur dit que le poisson
qu'ils achètent à tel endroit
ou tel type de poisson,
ça cause la mort de dauphins,
il y a beaucoup de gens qui vont dire :
"Bah non, moi je ne veux pas
supporter ce type de pêche
parce que je ne veux pas supporter
que ça tue des dauphins derrière."
Maintenant, on va aller voir
un organisme scientifique
qui s'appelle Pelagis.
C'est eux qui ont tous les chiffres
et qui ont tiré la sonnette d'alarme
par rapport à cette problématique.
Ils se trouvent à La Rochelle,
donc on va repartir sur terre
et on va aller les rencontrer.
- Bonjour.
On est dans une salle d'autopsie là.
Ces animaux,
on les a collectés en mars,
s'ils sont encore dans cet état-là,
c'est parce qu'on les conserve.
Là, on a des individus
qui sont à peu près de 10 ans,
sur une espérance de vie
de 30 à 35 ans.
Individu de bonne santé,
de bonne condition physique,
qui a des hématomes,
des coupes nettes, des abrasions,
donc une mort traumatique
avec l'apparence de contact filet,
donc voilà ce qui permet de déterminer
la mort par la capture accidentelle.
Ça, c'est notamment
du filet de fileyeur,
une maille de nylon
qui est très fine quoi,
très résistante aussi, c'est-à-dire que ça,
ça ne se casse pas comme ça.
On va faire
de la mise en scène hein,
mais lorsqu'on a un animal
qui se retrouve pris
sur une pectorale comme celle-là,
vous voyez,
ça tombe pile-poil là, la maille.
Exactement dans la rainure
et on voit bien que la dimension
de la maille correspond bien.
Je ne l'avais pas fait ça
comme manipulation,
et c'est marrant comment naturellement,
je dirais, ça se met bien en place en fait.
- C'est fou !
- Tous ces hématomes qu'on voit ici
et les hématomes
qui sont liés au contact filet,
eh bien proviennent, en fait,
de cet emprisonnement.
Donc ça, c'est une preuve indéniable
que l'animal était vivant,
parce que c'est vrai qu'un filet
pourrait collecter une carcasse
d'un animal mort
et là, malheureusement,
les animaux étaient vivants.
Je pense que le plus violent, encore,
c'est la mort agonique.
Toutes ces couleurs-là,
ce sont des très gros hématomes
qui sont liés en fait
aux vaisseaux qui éclatent
parce qu'ils sont
en train de s'asphyxier
et donc tout
le poumon entièrement
est même déchiré
par partie à l'intérieur.
Combien de temps
il peut rester un dauphin sous l'eau ?
20 minutes ?
20 à 30 minutes
suivant les espèces.
Il y a des capacités qui
sont plus importantes.
Après avec le stress,
cette capacité-là,
elle est réduite
de manière très importante.
Pourquoi vous avez besoin
de faire une autopsie
sachant qu'on est quasi sûrs,
on a des preuves des filets...
C'est vraiment pour pousser ?
Oui, déjà c'est pour avoir
tous les éléments factuels
parce que notamment en ce moment
nos diagnostics sont un petit peu contestés.
Et nous ce qui nous inquiète,
c'est que ces populations
ne soient pas maintenues dans le temps.
Si vous voulez
les captures accidentelles,
on connaît ça depuis
les années 80.
En 2017, on a battu
tous les records de la série
en termes d'effectif.
En 2018, on a battu
le record de 2017.
Et là, alors que la saison
je dirais où on a
cette problématique de capture
n'est pas finie parce que
c'est quasiment fin avril / début mai.
Eh bien, on a déjà dépassé
le record de l'année dernière
et très, très largement.
Combien d'animaux
vous avez depuis le début de l'année ?
Alors on a une comptabilité
de 1200 animaux.
C'est-à-dire que le nombre
de morts en mer
peut être multiplié
d'un facteur cinq.
Et là, on pense que ces prélèvements
ne permettent pas à la population
de se maintenir
sur le moyen ou long terme.
Les études démographiques
démontrent plutôt
qu'on pourrait perdre cette espèce
dans le golfe de Gascogne
à l'échelle de 50 ans.
Avec les deux qui sont
sur la table, en tout,